speaking of Intolerable uh moving into
this daily wire has this report former
president Barack Obama whitewashed the
Islamic terrorist attacks that Hamas
committed against Israel last month
where terrorists murdered 1400 Israelis
wounded 5,300 and kidnapped more than
240 people Obama made the remarks during
an appearance on the leftist podcast pod
save America late this week according to
a preview clip uh released by the
podcast
so it's kind of a long club and I
probably won't play the whole thing but
let's uh here here's Obama this I think
this the first time we've really heard
from him at least in person since
everything uh started um back in early
October and here's Obama in to save the
day with his uh what is supposed to be
his kind
of
sophisticated nuanced moral perspective
that's his whole stick right that's his
gimmick to pretend to be morally
sophisticated so he's the guy that's
going to come in then say no no no
you're you're all let me you're all
you're all so you simpletons let me let
me explain to you the the complexities
of this situation and he tries that
here um but not to spoil the ending
spends a lot of time babbling about it
at the end he says basically
nothing uh let's watch if there's any
chance of us being able to act
constructively to do
something it will require an admission
of
complexity and maintaining what on the
surface may seem contr okay pause just
pause for it's exactly what I'm talking
about we must
maintain or we it requires an admission
of
complexity what does that mean exactly
so right off the bat he just has phrases
like this that he drops it's it's
instinctive for him phrases that
maybe on the on the surface initially if
you're if you're naive may sound
smart um and then you think about it for
one second you say what ises that wait
what admission of
complexity okay let's continue that that
what Hamas did was horrific and there's
no justification for
it and what is also true is
that the the occupation
and what's happening to
Palestinians
is is
unbearable and what is also true is that
there is a
history of the Jewish people
that may be dismissed unless your
grandparents or your great grandparents
or your uncle or your aunt tell you
stories
about the madness Okay let me pause one
second I can't even listen to this there
everything about it including the tone
of voice this is this is maybe a pet
peeve on my part but it's very common
these days that people
speak and then they you know the tone
their their tone goes up at the end of
the sentence to make it sound like every
sentence is a question and that's
exactly what we're hearing here every
statement he makes it notice at the end
the tone goes up so that every statement
is phrased like a question and I don't
know what that is exactly or when that
became popular
but people like Obama this is this is
what you always hear uh but we haven't
gotten to the to the most absurd part
yet so we got to we got to keep
listening
semitism and what is true is that there
are people right now who are
dying who have nothing to do with what
Hamas did and what is true right I I
mean we can go on for a while and the
problem with the social media and trying
to tick
tock activism and trying to debate this
on
that is you can't speak the truth you
can pretend to speak the truth you can
speak one side of the
truth and in some cases you can try to
maintain your moral innocence but that
won't solve the problem and so if you
want to solve the problem then you have
to take in the whole
truth and you then have to
admit nobody's hands are
clean
that all of us are complicit to some
degree okay I this and I
think well actually no I want let's this
last part let's listen to this go ahead
think back what could I have done during
my presidency to move this forward okay
all right so that was it that's what I
wanted to get to so most people are
focusing on the moral equivalence of it
and he's just rambling and not saying
anything uh you know it's rather than
simply
stating um when terrorists go into a
country and Massacre and some people
it's it's a horrible thing he can't he
can't just say that
he has to list do this moral
equivocation back and forth back and
forth until you lose track of what you
were even talking about and that's
really the point here it's just it's
just it's it is a obfuscation disguised
as being morally sophisticated so most
people are focusing on that and for good
reason but I love that part at the end
there where he says
um all none of our hands are clean and
we have to realize well we're all
complicit
what no br my hands are clean on this
one I I'm not complicit at all I will
tell you right now I'm not a perfect man
by any means I have nothing to do with
any of this I am not remotely complicit
or even partially uh to blame for
anything that is happening in the Middle
East actually anywhere in the Middle
East none of it has anything to do with
me I could have never existed and it
would all be happening exactly as it is
currently happening okay um maybe I
would like to think that I am as an
individual so ific that everything on
the planet would be different if I
didn't exist but that's not the case so
if I never existed everything currently
happening would still be happening
everything that happened on October 7th
would have still happened everything
happening uh in Israel would have still
happen and that's the case for you
whoever you are watching this most
likely right you may you're an important
person every life is cherished every
life every human life is important but
uh you could have never existed and all
of this stuff would still be happening
so you are not remotely complicit in any
of this you have nothing to do with
it same for me but so this statement
from him well we're all complicit who's
to say yes the Hamas terrorists they
went into Israel and they massacred
innocent people but but we're all all of
our hands are are dirty we've all we're
all partially responsible for that
what explain that and of course the pods
save America dudes are just sitting
there soaking this all in that there's
no follow-up question okay there's no
hang what was that can you explain that
a little bit what do you mean we're all
complicit you got an audience full of
people I mean how what did they do to
contribute to this they didn't do
anything the holidays are coming up fast
and while you're out shopping for your
kids family and friends don't forget to
shop for your pets too I never do give
your dog the gift of a healthier and
happier life with Ruff greens
naturopathic Dr Dr Dennis black the
founder of Ruff greens is focused on on
improving the health of every dog in
America before I started feeding my dog
rough greens I had no idea that dog food
is dead food it contains very little
nutritional value think about it
nutrition isn't Brown it's green let
rough greens bring your dog's food back
to life rough greens is a supplement
that contains all the necessary vitamins
minerals probiotics Omega oils digestive
enzymes and antioxidants that your dog
needs you don't have to go out and buy
new dog food you just sprinkle rough
Greens on their food every day dog
owners everywhere are raving about rough
greens it supports healthy joints
improves bad breath boosts energy levels
and so much more we are what we eat and
that goes for dogs too naturopathic Dr
Dennis black is so confident Ru greens
will improve your dog's health he's
offering my listeners a free jumpstart
trial bag so your dog can try it get a
free jump start trial bag delivered
straight to your door in just a few
business days go to Ru greens.com mat or
call 844 ru700 that's rffg greens.com
mat or call 844 Ruff 700
today and then to support that statement
he says you know we're all it and I
think of myself and what could I have
done yeah well you were the
president so
yes if you want to give yourself some of
the blame you're the you were the
president of the United States of
America for eight years you were in
charge of American foreign policy you
made decisions about the things that we
were going to do
overseas and so if you're looking at the
state of the world and saying to
yourself it looks pretty bad right now
maybe I could have done more maybe I
could have done things differently you
should be saying that
so no no no Brock it's not we don't all
share the blame you share some of the
blame but that doesn't mean we all do
because only you were
president maybe he's saying that
everyone shares the blame because he he
is partially responsible according to
him and anyone who voted for him is
therefore partially responsible that I
mean maybe in that sense sure I guess I
mean if Barack Obama is admitting
according to his his own admission that
he's partially complicit in what's
happening in the Middle
East if that's the case then I guess
people who voted for him do share some
of the blame they put them there but I
didn't vote for him either
so I didn't I didn't vote for any of the
people that are causing this problem uh
or contributing to it I had nothing to
do with it so no we are not all
complicit we do not all share the
blame and uh you know I know I'm taking
this literally because it's such a
literally ridiculous thing to say but he
doesn't mean for it to be taken he
doesn't mean he doesn't mean for it to
be taken any way at all he's just
babbling he's babbling around the
issue but the the the underlying point
is uh to
avoid condemning evil
acts and the people who choose to carry
them out this is all a elaborate way
around any kind of personal
responsibility because when any bad
thing
happens okay or I should say when any
bad Act is committed anywhere in the
world um there are people responsible
for committing that
act and then there might be other people
who are indirectly um uh responsible or
indirectly contributed to
it okay so the the
blame might fall squarely and only on
the shoulders of the person who does it
or the people who do it uh it may go
beyond
that but it is not true to say that
we're all responsible for every bad
thing that
happens and you only try to claim that
if you want to avoid again personal
responsibility if you want to avoid
blaming the people who actually carry
the blame and who are
responsible hey YouTube thanks for
listening to the show if you'd like
access to my full show with no ads you
should go to dailywire.com and use promo
code Walsh to get two months free on all
annual plans see you there